ersten 30 sekunden denke ich immer noch
ich muss mich anstellen ich muss mich
anstellen ich falle gleich runter
ich bin ja schon mal so schnell gefahren
250 dass mein hirn hat die ganze zeit
geschrieben gefährlich gefährlich sagt
ihm sofort dass er aufhören soll aber
meinen so von meinem ganzen gefühle habe
ich gedacht ich will dass uns
weitermachen das ist total faszinierend
heute fahren wir ein motorrad von neben
walter mir schon von anfang an gesagt
hat dass ich danach eine psychotherapie
machen müsste und zwar eine ducati
panigale eine rennmaschine die
normalerweise ohne beifahrersitz
ausgeliefert wird und er musste hart
kämpfen dass er den bekommen hat also
eigentlich bin ich gar nicht vorgesehen
auf dem motorrad ich glaube das wird
sehr sehr aufregend und es wird so eine
mischung aus angst und nervenkitzel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am anfang habe ich gedacht ich fühle
mich eigentlich wie eine trägerrakete
weil ich jetzt so weit über ihn dass
jedes mal wenn er bremst meinen hintern
sich in die luft hebt und ich denke ich
stehe es nach vorne über ihn drüber
das ist wirklich um also eine kraft die
ich noch nie selber gespürt hab' ich
hatte schon richtiges magengrummeln also
nicht dass mir schlecht gewesen wäre
aber mein magen war der ansicht das sei
zu viel ich eigentlich nicht mehr hat
spaß gemacht und ja auch eigentlich habe
ich die spitze das wird aber wohl keine
angst reichs gewesen sein sondern eher
weil es zu warm
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass mehr
motorrad fahren spaß macht was ich daran
halt mag ist dass das so viel
dynamischer ist als autofahren
[Musik]